très le marché parce qu'il a cette force
en question qui est la force les banques
centrales est trop forte
[Musique]
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président la république d'haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode crapuleux l'on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieuse cela ne peut que contribuer à
la dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tout ça nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter des grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 14 septembre
contrôle parlementaire des forces de
l'ordre doublement des effectifs sur le
terrain en disant augmentation budget
d'un milliard et demi en 2022 pauvre le
ministère de l'intérieur emmanuel macron
a clôturé aujourd'hui la vaste
consultation du bureau de la sécurité
l'elysée qui évoque des annonces
substantielle et des changements
radicaux à quelques mois d'élections
présidentielles alors vrai changement de
fond ou poudre aux yeux ce sera
l'instant décryptage avec nos invités
anthony blinken défend le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan
auditionné à la chambre des
représentants le secrétaire d'état
américain a contesté les accusations
d'un préparation et de trahison pointant
du doigt la responsabilité de donald
trump pour les républicains au contraire
ce fiasco imputé à joe biden est une
reddition inconditionnelle face aux
talibans on soit en direct des états
unis
au sommaire de cette émission également
alors que la pandémie continue sa décrue
en france plusieurs centaines de
personnes des milliers selon la
cgt-santé ont manifesté contre
l'obligation vaccinale qui s'appliquera
à partir de demain au personnel des
hôpitaux et maisons de retraite alors
l'intérêt général doit-il primer sur
l'intérêt et la liberté individuelle est
il légitime d'opposer les deux comment
les hôpitaux où vont-ils s'adapter à
cette nouvelle
ur du gouvernement ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
emmanuel macron arroub est donc
aujourd'hui sur les terres de xavier
bertrand pour la clôture du bourreau de
la sécurité une consultation débuter
cette année entre le gouvernement castex
et les syndicats de police plusieurs
mois de concertation pour améliorer
leurs conditions d'exercice mais aussi
consolider le lien avec les français
pour en parler on retrouve 4,6 à pique
nique place beauvau bonsoir 4k que
retenir de ces annonces des manuels
macro aujourd'hui
bonsoir stéphanie bien le président a
fait une dizaine d'annoncés avec une
volonté affichée de changer la donne il
faut dire que nos chefs d'état n'étaient
pas en terrain conquis 1 face aux
policiers aux gendarmes des hauts de
france et de xavier bertrand son
éventuel futur rival à la présidentielle
xavier bertrand qui avait fait qualifier
sa politique de sécurité intérieure
d'échec profond alors face à cette
critique et d'autre le président a
annoncé une loi de programmation pour la
sécurité intérieure qui sera présenté au
conseil des ministres au début de
l'année à 2022 ce qui signifie
évidemment qu'elle ne sera pas prête
avant la présidentielle et emmanuel
macron une annonce importante veut
davantage de bleu comme il l'a dit sur
le terrain une présence de jour comme de
nuit sept jours sur sept et pour cela il
faudra évidemment réorganiser le temps
de travail et réaffecter des tâches il
souhaite également la mise en place de
plainte en ligne d'ici 2023 pour le
moment ce n'est pas possible il ya que
l'après plainte au niveau de la
formation ça s'éteint un moment
important de son allocution il souhaite
la renforcer pour qu'elle soit plus
longue et qualifiantes quatre mois de
plus s'est également renforcé la
formation continue de 50% toujours non
en ce domaine il souhaite la création
d'un centre de formation sur le maintien
de l'ordre en région parisienne pour les
policiers puisque de nombreuses
critiques ont été émises sur la question
du maintien de l'ordre particulièrement
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
toujours dans cette optique il y aura la
craie sion d'une instance parlementaire
de contrôle des forces de l'ordre pour
procéder je cite à l'évaluation de leurs
actions une instance indépendante avait
en effet été réclamée par de nombreux
députés de l'opposition
et pour cela et bien emmanuel macron va
débloquer les moyens je vous propose de
l'écouter
en 2022 le ministère de l'intérieur
verra ainsi son budget augmenter de près
de 1,5 milliard d'euros dont 500
millions d'euros pour la mise en oeuvre
des premières mesures du beauvau de la
sécurité c'est sans précédent
95 %
95 % de ces mesures qui ressorte du
beauvau sont pour du matériel de
l'investissement les conditions de
travail
autre annonce une simplification
drastique de la procédure pénale qui
était demandée par les associations et
les syndicats de policiers avec une
consultation du garde des sceaux à la
clé le déploiement de 30 mille caméras
piétons de bonne qualité pour éviter les
dérapages lors des interpellations une
réserve opérationnelle de la police d'en
doter de 30000 réservistes va être créée
il y aura également une suppression du
rappel à la loi un qui était demandé par
les forces de l'ordre davantage d'amande
forfaitaire sur le modèle de celles qui
sont dressés lors de la consommation de
cannabis et pour terminer stéphanie la
création de nouveaux uniformes avec un
polo moderniser un calot pour remplacer
la casquette vous voyez stéphanie le
changement c'est maintenant apparemment
effectivement katia technique et un
discours on n'oublie pas quand même très
politique avec les annonces qui
ressemble furieusement à celle du
candidat maquereau en 2017 alors ces
mesures c'est
ce sont des effets d'annoncé sont ceux
sont un véritable changement de fond
quel avenir pour la police de 2030 c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler jean pierre
colombier ce retraité de la police vous
êtes également parle parole de l'une
l'inpi l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ce plateau sur rt
france bruno bartocetti
également avec nous toujours active vous
êtes le secrétaire au dessus du syndicat
unité sgp police fo bonsoir merci d'être
également avec nous alors il en fallait
un petit peu de temps pour
dire toutes ces annonces on va aller
essayer de décrypter ensemble on va
écouter encore une fois emmanuel lacroix
revente vous faire réagir qui a
multiplié les promesses aujourd'hui
le but est de penser la police et la
gendarmerie de 2030 une police qui doit
faire face aux nouvelles formes de
délinquance qui pullulent dans l'espace
numérique le deal par messagerie crypté
les escroqueries digital la
cybercriminalité une police qui doit se
saisir des technologies numériques pour
aller plus vite enquêter plus
efficacement une police qui doit être
formé et équipé en fonction des
nouvelles menaces qui pèsent sur la
société le terrorisme mais aussi la
violence débridée les manifestations
sporadiques
l'internationalisation du crime et je
veux nous fixer un horizon
augmenter significativement
c'est à dire doubler sous dix ans la
présence des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique
argent bien colombien s'est
effectivement ça en fait des annonces on
va tenter d'y voir clair déjà ce que
vous êtes un policier heureux ce soir
avec tous ces cadeaux qui monte en
dessus
bonsoir mais c'est surtout la population
qui doit être ou satisfaites ou pas de
ce qui est annoncé bonjour je crois
qu'il faut être un petit peu sérieux on
a eu droit aujourd'hui un véritable
discours de campagne avec
une sorte de deux récitals à la prévert
de défunts on a tous au cours de ce
discours qui étaient très longs
quasiment interminable pendant plus
d'une heure ou en fait on a une
énumération de dossiers qui sont déjà
très bien connu et bien avant le bouvau
de la sécurité tout ce qui a été évoqué
l'aménagement des horaires la
répartition nouvelles des effectifs sur
le terrain on pourrait effectivement le
reprendre au cours de cette année
l'émission alors on a
globalement globalement je crois qu'il
faut pas être trop naïf on sent bien que
le président a voulu faire plaisir à
tout le monde à la fois aux policiers
qui étaient présents et à la fois à
certains à certaines associations qui a
également réclamé plus de contrôle de
l'action policière et on voit que cette
annonce de cet organisme ou fonds ne
sait pas trop de quoi il s'agit puisque
ni monsieur casta dernier le président
n'a vraiment décrypter en quoi les
consisté ce fameux contrôler leur
contrôle de jpm et concret par la
création d'une institution réellement
indépendante ou une sorte de nébuleuse
parlementaire qui viendraient en supra
évaluer l'action de la police c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça
n'est pas clair du tout on va reparler
dans un second temps de se contrôler
vous bruno bartocetti vous êtes plutôt
séduits par ces mesures annoncées par
emmanuel macron ou alors effet d'annonce
comme semble le penser votre comparse
sur ce plateau ou véritable changement
de fond c'est vrai que ça rappelle on le
précise quelques promesses de campagne
qui date de 2010 est un
oui bonsoir on est forcément séduit
lorsque nous parle à l'horizon
2020 2023 un milliard c'est un million
de petits dans le cadre de la loppsi 2
la loi de rénovation
donc forcément on utilise attentif à ce
genre d'
anormale ce qui est important c'est de
retenir bien sûr que
les sunlights de thé routine que présida
m'apprend aujourd'hui et a tué un cadre
de son nous sommes deux les élections
présidentielles et c'est à nous être
très vigilant là dessus évidemment on
accueilli cette annonce avec beaucoup
d'intérêt
comment ça va être appliquée c'est autre
chose mais de toute façon ma prend un
autre
seront obligés de moderniser notre notre
police car nous avons aujourd'hui la
nécessité d'y vont évoluer dans ce sens
pourquoi parce que nous policiers on
s'adapte à des difficultés de
fonctionnement à des
fonctionnements drastique et alors que
céline bears il faut nous donner les
moyens de travailler bien évidemment au
pouvoir participer j'insiste là-dessus
participer sur sur la sécurité parce que
tout ne doit pas reposer sur les épaules
de la police et de la justice à
beautiran de sécurité alors on va
écouter une première réaction politique
aujourd'hui celle du rassemblement
national eurodéputés gilbert collard
miracle à six mois des élections
présidentielles macron se rend compte
que les policiers sont mal traités que
les effectifs manque et que la paperasse
administrative les écrase il se fout de
nous jean-pierre colombien seriez
je n'ai peut-être pas paraphraser maître
collard mais
il pas tout à fait loigné d'une certaine
réalité ça fait effectivement des années
des années que le diagnostic sur la
paupérisation de la police effet il ya
quand même quelques oubliés dans son
discours en et l'oublier le mal être des
fonctionnaires de police avec le
phénomène des suicides qui est toujours
prégnant qui est toujours là et là je
n'ai pas entendu sur ce sujet là de la
même manière qu'ils n'évoquent pas
l'état désespérant de l'outil judiciaire
de la justice alors semble-t-il que ça
doit faire là encore l'objet d'un
nouveau débat avec
les membres de la magistrature enfin bon
il faut arrêter aussi de prendre les
gens pour ce qu'ils ne sont pas c'est à
dire des naïfs le diagnostic a été posé
il existe depuis longtemps c'est pas mon
collègue mon ex-collègue ce que
syndicaliste qui dira le contraire mais
enfin tout était déjà sur la table tout
était déjà dans l'est dans les bureaux
du ministère
je pense que là je vais être assez
sévère je pense que c'est tout
simplement pas dans son adn c'est
l'aspect sécuritaire n'est pas dans son
adn on l'a bien vu il a nommé très tôt
des ministres de l'intérieur qui de mon
point de vue n'étaient pas à leur place
gérard collomb n'était pas à sa place
christophe castaner on l'a bien vu a été
très contestée et à juste titre pour des
prises de paroles des prises de position
et des attitudes particulièrement
décalage avec ce qui se passait sur le
terrain et aujourd'hui on a crise gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur qui à
l'époque faut quand même remonter un
petit peu dans l'histoire a fait partie
dé cabinet de nicolas sarkozy qui nous a
quand même déflatés considérablement et
nous a affaiblis avec des réformes de la
procédure qui aujourd'hui encore alourdi
celle ci et je
pourrais en parler effectivement très
longuement mais la nomination aussi
d'eric dupond-moretti pose problème il
n'a eu de cesse que de dénoncer
l'appareil judiciaire s'est fait un
ennemi quelque part de tout ce qui
pouvait s'opposer à son métier d'avocat
parce que quand j'entends parler de
simplification procédurales excusez moi
de sourire d'avoir un sourire un peu
cynique parce que si c'est bien
quelqu'un s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît un ralentissement de la
procédure c'est bien lui donc je ne vois
pas comment tout à coup ces personnages
qui avait au fond d'eux un vraie volonté
plutôt de ne pas faire pourrait tout à
coup être de grands réformiste de
l'institution police justice qui sont
parfaitement indissociables si on veut
réformer durablement et
significativement le l'institution
judiciaire dans son ensemble
bruno bartocetti vous êtes d'accord avec
ce diagnostic de jean-pierre colombiès
emmanuel macron qui n'a pas
nécessairement la sécurité dans son adn
et qui on le rappelle
s'est rendu aujourd'hui sur les terres
d'ailleurs de xavier bertrand qui nous
fait le même reproche et qui sera
peut-être un de ses concurrents à la
présidentielle et et on essaye de
rattraper le temps perdu peut-être trop
beau pour être vrai en si peu de temps
alors il est clair que c'est à nous cela
aurait été accueillie avec une puce de
satisfaction il y a quelques années en
arrière ceci étant et pour rejoindre
aussi mon ex-collègue
et il fait bien de le souligner c'est
très important nous avons perdu beaucoup
d'effectifs sous sarkozy nous avons
perdu 13 me de 700 postes de policiers
et jeunes entre 2004 et 2012 et à partir
de 2012 j&j a aucune connotation
politique de ma part puisque notre
organisation syndicale ne s'est pas
exprimée avant les élections
présidentielles de 2017 elle ne le fera
pas avant
positionné derrière aucun candidat donc
j'en parle librement je donne juste
quelques dates à partir de 2012
recrutement a été fait dans la police
mais à 5 ans a été insuffisant en a pas
rééquilibré le mcs d'effectifs sous mac
row on a continué à recruter mais ne
perdons pas de vue une chose essentielle
ce qu'il a fallu renforcer les
renseignements territoriaux la tête j'ai
ici et c'est vrai que ça a
malheureusement d'enlever les policiers
qui sommes sur le terrain alors je ne
veux pas être l'avocat de
maquereau en matière d'effectifs mais
sûrement sur le problème des effectifs
et on a perdu beaucoup d'effectifs
depuis depuis presque vingt ans il va
falloir des décennies pour pour les
récupérer après en revanche et je
rejoins mon collègue de là dessus sur la
procédure pénale
ça fait très longtemps qu'on tire la
sonnette d'alarmé c'est de plus en plus
lourd pour nos collègues enquêteurs de
travailler lorsqu'on parle de sécurité
aujourd'hui sur le terrain tout ne doit
pas reposer sur les policiers en tenue
qui vont en pâtir occuper le terrain
lorsqu'on veut démanteler réellement en
réseau par exemple si vous permettez de
stupéfiants ce sont des mois et des mois
dans lequel est si on atteint des
résultats de moi on va faire tomber deux
guetteurs et un dealer donc donnant les
moyens aux enquêteurs de travailler je
le dis sous le contrôle de mon collègue
qui était un policier judiciaire je ne
peux pas donnant les moyens aux
enquêteurs de travailler pour
politiquement répondre à une atteinte
sérieuse en matière de délinquance
autour des stupéfiants et de lady trafic
d'armes voilà ça c'est très important
c'est à dire que tout ne doit pas
reposer sur la présence policière est
nécessaire déjà nous pour qu'on puisse
travailler en sécurité pour construire
trois chefs de cette population qui nous
soutient je vous le dis bien cette
population ne soutient je pense que vous
allez venir sur ce thème là mais on a
besoin aussi de donner les moyens aux
enquêteurs de travailler et cette
procédure pénale voilà ça moi vous savez
je vais pas je ne vais pas faire le
procès du ministre la justice mais
franchement on est fatigué on peut pas
travailler aujourd'hui dans ces
conditions c'est très lourd de procédure
pénale les avocats de fass démontre nos
dossiers nos procédures sur la forme
parce qu'on est sonné à l'on dit par des
tâches très lourde en matière de
procédure alors il ya un discours un
petit peu dissonante parmi les réactions
politiques aujourd'hui
celui du porte-parole la france soumise
david lee roth compose de l'écouter
je rappelle que la police a été le
secteur de la société qui a été le plus
choyé dans les discours politiques et
les mesures sous emmanuel macron quand
vous êtes capitaine de police
c'est-à-dire bac + 3 vous gagnez 2400
euros quand vous êtes professeur des
écoles à bac +5 vous entré en fonctions
avec 1400 euros il faut arrêter de dire
que les policiers subissent un
traitement de défaveur ça n'est pas vrai
jean-pierre colombiès vous réagissez
comme en as les propos de du porte
parole la france insoumise finalement
vous n'êtes pas si mal traités que ça je
lui répondrais très simplement que c'est
surtout un des métiers depuis difficile
à exercer et que ça se paye point barre
et je trouve que ça mériterait même
encore une revalorisation de certains
points des indices mais ça c'est un
débat qui nous amènerait très loin je
crois pour revenir sur ce cas dit
emmanuel macron je crois qu'il faut un
peu un peu de cohérence et d'honnêteté
dans ce qu'on dit dans ce qu'on fait et
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'on en est loin pourquoi je dis cela
c'est tout simplement parce que dans le
livre blanc qui était portée par
monsieur fauvergue qui a oublié quelque
part d'où il venait il fait la part
belle aux polices municipales et aux
sociétés de sécurité privées et tout ça
n'a qu'un but qu'un objectif c'est de
substituer aux services publics une
sorte de
phare on donne un blanc seing pour ainsi
dire à une forme de justice privée qui
est pour de mon point de vue
complètement contestable qui va à
l'encontre même de l'intérêt général
faut savoir ce qu'on veut c'est bien
gentil de faire des discours en disant
aux policiers on a besoin de vous on
compte sur vous on sait que c'est très
dur patin couffin tout ça sauf que dans
le même temps vous faites exactement
inverse et que vous défendez les
sociétés privées qui vont se substituer
aux forces de police on nous rabat les
oreilles notamment avec les caméras
problème des caméras fallait caméra
c'est pas un outil pour empêcher les
agressions c'est un outil de réaction
c'est plutôt pour élucider des
agressions qui ont eu lieu mais en aucun
cas cela ne peut remplacer un policier
sur le terrain alors moi je veux bien
qu'on nous annonce la multiplication des
policiers par deux d'ici quelques années
apparemment on l'a on est un peu dans la
fiction dans la police fiction parce que
on en est très loin puisque ça
s'opposent à des règles obligent et
budgétaires très strictes qui nous sont
imposées d'ailleurs par l'europe et donc
tout ça ça va nécessiter la mise en
oeuvre de plan de dispositifs financiers
très lourds et je ne suis pas certain je
suis même certain du contraire qu'on
arrive à
mettre en place concrètement ses
promesses on est vraiment dans le cadre
des promesses et il croire à qui veut
bien y croire vous parliez tout à
l'heure on aurait eu besoin peut-être
que que le président macron s'intéresse
aussi au moral des policiers évoquant
ces suicides hasard du calendrier cette
affaire qui a fait parler aujourd'hui
une enseigne qui a retiré un smoothie 1
où l'on peut voir des slogans comme à 4
qui n'est rien moins que l'acronyme de
all cops d'un master 1 traduction les
flics sont des bâtards je voudrais vous
faire écouter avant de vous faire réagir
quand une marque de jus de fruits fait
son beurre sur la haine anti-flic le
parfait mode d'emploi pour détruire des
relations police population
des réactions bruno bartocetti vous
cautionnez justement cette réaction
illustration d'une dérive vous auriez
attendu peut-être des mots d'amour de la
part du président en tout cas voilà un
peu de un peu de réconfort également
oui forcément puisque de soissons vous
savez le policier aujourd'hui même s'il
est très courageuse il est très
professionnel il est il est fatigué on
va dire justement toutes ces attaques et
qui sont faites à l'endroit d'un
policier républicaine vous savez j'ai
assisté bien là dessus
travaillons pour bien sûr interpeller
les auteurs une bonne somme victimes et
nous sommes nous mêmes à la sécurité il
ya une insécurité moral également il est
évident qu'on attend de nos politiques
de président de la république d'un
premier ministre de ministre quel qu'il
soit on attend 2 2 un soutien
malheureusement on est souvent pris dans
un étau politique quel que soit le
gouvernement peut faire leur chemin sur
quarante ans en arrière on est sûr
d'alizée on est fatigués et on continue
à travailler avec beaucoup de force ce
qui est intolérable aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment c'est de voir cette marque de
jus de fruit ou la france est soumise
j'emploie français subissent leur donne
trop d'importance
les sites qui font leur beurre on va
dire sur sur le dos des policiers en les
ciblant les agresseurs c'est vraiment
honteux parce que personne n'est naïf on
sait pardonner vous en 2015 c'est pas
vieux c'est serré sans la france entière
vous soutenez est ce que les policiers
ont chargé la population a changé la
population à la table mais à terme
beaucoup de nos politiques que pascal
est elle si cette nature on a besoin de
moyens pour répondre au service si ceux
qui nous soutiennent on est soutenus par
la population certainement pas politique
je veux oui oui à des gens dans mon jeu
je peux que confirmer abondé dans ce
sens donc vraiment la police a besoin
mais pas se voir la police un châssis
est bien là dessus la population la
population a besoin de ministres
responsables qui met vraiment en avant
qui est vraiment comme souci mais unique
souci l'intérêt général tout simplement
et qu'ils cessent de faire de la police
une sorte d' ajustement de variable
d'ajustement lorsque par exemple il ya
des conflits sociaux très importants
comme l'inconnu avec le jus des jaunes
qu'on cesse de se servir de la police
comme régulateur social justement aller
et venir jean-pierre colombien c'est
bruno bartocetti et puisque vous parlez
de ces manifestations il ya eu une forme
de réponse à ses présumées violences
policières qui sont souvent en tout cas
mis sur le devant de la scène par vos
détracteurs emmanuel macron qui annonce
donc la création d'une instance à on en
parlait parlementaire de contrôle des
forces de l'ordre l'igpn ne
suffisent-elles pas non mais enfin
c'est presque drôle d'entendre ça faut
savoir quand même que lorsqu'il ya des
dysfonctionnements majeurs je me
rappelle quand même la sphère benalla il
aurait pu s'en souvenir monsieur macron
il ya une commission dans quatre qu'il
était nommé
le sénat s'est penché sur le problème
sur les dysfonctionnements potentielle
qui pourrait exister lors des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre mais la police ne
fait que ce qu'on lui demande de faire
faut jamais perdre ça de vue bien ce qui
s'est passé pendant l'épisode qu'on a
appelés gilles et je le regrette
d'ailleurs ce vocable parce que pour moi
ça correspond pas grand chose mais on
s'est quand même rendu compte et je
pourrais avoir commenté de bien souvent
sur des plateaux de télé cette situation
aurait dû être neutralisée bien avant en
amont ça n'aurait jamais dû durer aussi
longtemps avec autant de violence de
part et d'autre avec une stratégie une
philosophie d'emploi de maintien d'ordre
était complètement incohérente la
technique de la nasse la technique de
contact qui était validée par le
président macron et qui à ce point à
radicaliser l'opposition citoyenne
police il en est lui-même le responsable
quand il nomme un préfet de police comme
didier lallement qui n'osent pas qu'ils
n'hésitent pas pardon à se comparer et
qui ne renonce pas la comparaison le
général galliffet le massacreur de la
commune là vous vous dites qu'il ya un
vrai problème donc il faut arrêter aussi
de faire croire que des policiers sont
des gens sont presque des enfants d
immature qui ferait à peu près n'importe
quoi sur le terrain sentiment d'être un
petit peu instrumentalisé bruno
bartocetti le mot de la fin parce qu'on
arrive déjà à la fin de notre
décryptage en de ces annonces nombreuses
d'emmanuel macron justement ce contrôle
indépendant qui viendrait des
parlementaires vous vous l'avez reçu
comment dans votre syndicat et vous
personnellement tout simplement l'igpn
ne suffisait pas
l'egypte elle suffit largement parce que
j'ai fait n'est pas là pour vous faire
des cadeaux
si on doit contrôler le travail de
litchi pénombre ou si on doit contribuer
encore une fois le travail de la police
avec une organisme supplémentaires on se
retrouve dans une nuit le foeil vous
savez nous avons rien à cacher parce
qu'on est on se retrouve demain dgpn ne
sommes pas à l'aise même le sto n'a rien
à se reprocher je vais pas dire que j'ai
fait le travail à charge mais on peut se
poser parfois la question quant aux dix
policiers quand on se retrouve devant le
gîte est donc encore une fois c'est un
contrôle d'un contrôle d'un contrôle
vous avez les chapelles vous avez pigé à
l'élection générale administrative ça
devient lourd pour nous parce que nous
faisons notre travail et l'austérité
nous tous avec un siège au conseil de
discipline hommes traduit des policiers
qui ont fauté trouve au les sanctions
adaptées merten surtout que la grande
majorité des cas les poules ici
travaillent avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme et si vous m'accordez
un petit instant sur le mettre en ordre
métier de l'ordre surtout sachez
retenant que nous avons affaibli des
effectifs chez les crs chez les ja
avaient laissé les crs un doute la
matière de maintien de l'ordre alors
sont très professionnels au contraire
renforcé en forçant les compagnies de
sécurité au travail ont été
très cohérent et x et sachant rendre
justement à la police des valeurs de
l'ordre et qui cale à travers justement
cette parité puis de manière
professionnelle parce que
malheureusement on prend des cas qui
sont des eaux mais aussi notre
institution c'est vraiment regrettable a
ajouté un tout petit morgan complétés le
propos sur lequel je suis parfaitement
d'accord sur les peines pour quand même
pas perdre de vue une chose c'est que
l'igpn traite des affaires
administratives
certes effectivement mais tout ce qui
est enquête préliminaire ou même de
flagrance ou deux sur commission
rogatoire se fait sous le contrôle des
magistrats déjà donc c'est pas faut pas
croire que dix gp n est une entité
autonome qui ferait un peu ce qu'elle
veut qui enquêterait au moment où le en
fonction du vent du tout non il ya un
contrôle des magistrats faut jamais
l'oublier et d'un fort était aussi le
débat hypocrite merci en tout cas à tous
les deux jean-pierre colombienne bruno
bartocetti d'avoir été avec nous suite
n'ont qu'à ses nombreuses annonces des
manuels macron aujourd'hui et alors donc
que le chef de l'état vient d'exposer sa
vision de la sécurité en france et un
rapport accablant que publier un essai
international sur le sujet des gendarmes
français lohan j'ai enquêté sur les
événements de redon en juin dernier
selon l'organisation les fonctionnaires
se sont rendus coupables d'un usage
disproportionné de la force les détails
en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
et on part maintenant aux états unis
anthony blinken a défendu cette nuit
leur très critiquée des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan mise en oeuvre
par joe biden le chef de la diplomatie
américaine entendus pour le deuxième
jour consécutif par le congrès après
avoir fait face hier à la chambre des
représentants il a répondu aujourd'hui
aux questions et d'une commission
sénatoriale on retrouve notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnet
bonsoir thomass que peut-on retenir de
cette audition aujourd'hui
et bien c'est une audition comme celle
d'hier qui a lieu dans un contexte
évidemment très compliqué pour
l'exécutif ici aux etats-unis anthony
blinken a en quelque sorte endosser la
responsabilité de ce retrait devant le
congrès il a dû donc défendre cette
décision pour le moins controversé
devant les élus américains beaucoup de
critiques ont été exprimées lors de ces
deux auditions notamment évidemment de
la part d'élus républicains alors la
première explication qui était attendue
c'était de savoir sur quels éléments
s'était appuyé le président joe biden
pour prendre cette décision du retrait
des troupes américaines écouté les
explications d'anthony pinker
en janvier 2021 les talibans étaient
plus fort militairement que jamais
depuis en septembre si nous avions le
plus faible nombre de soldats sur place
depuis 2001
en conséquence dès sa prise de fonction
le président biden a été confronté à un
choix
mettre fin à la guerre ou engager une
escalade s'il n'avait pas donné suite à
la promesse de son prédécesseur les
attaques contre nos forces et nos alliés
auraient repris et les assauts des
talibans sur les grandes villes afghanes
pourrait commencer
mais la question centrale qui a animé
les débats c'est de savoir pourquoi les
autorités américaines n'ont pas anticipé
la progression des taliban là encore
anthony blinken a tenté de se défendre
mais beaucoup de sénateurs notamment ont
souligné le fait que des informations
auraient pu voir aurait dû mener à une
décision voire une stratégie
complètement différente c'est le cas par
exemple du sénateur de floride marco
rubio écouter cet échange entre donc ce
sénateur républicain et le chef de la
diplomatie américaine
nous aurions dû savoir que lorsque nous
avons commencé à baisser notre appui
envers l'armée afghane nous allions voir
le risque d'un effondrement et c'est
aussi tout ce que ces preuves démontrent
donc c'est inquiétant que personne n'ait
vu tout ça et qu'il a été conclu qu'il
n'y avait pas de preuves ou de raisons
de croire qu'il pourrait y avoir un
effondrement rapide
rien de ce que j'ai vu ce que nous avons
vu pouvait laisser suggérer que ce
gouvernement et les forces de sécurité
allait s'effondrer en jour
et vous avez raison nous devons regarder
en arrière sur tout ça parce que nous
avons collectivement investi sur ces
vingt dernières années des sommes
astronomiques dans l'effort de sécurité
le gouvernement
des centaines de milliards de dollars
dans l'équipement les entraînements axés
terreur
et en se basant là-dessus encore une
fois nous n'avons pas vu cet
effondrement arrivé en quelques jours
mais c'est important que nous regardions
derrière nous et que nous analysions
tout ça
beaucoup d'autres points ont été abordés
lors de ces deux auditions qui ont été
très dense parmi les points abordés il
ya la difficulté d'établir des liens
diplomatiques avec les talibans en
afghanistan ou encore et bien la place
des femmes justement dans le pays ou
encore le fait que l'afghanistan puisse
à nouveau abriter des organisations
terroristes à l'avenir d'ailleurs on a
appris aujourd'hui que les services de
renseignement américains avaient affirmé
que d'ici un an ou deux ans al qaïda
pourrait de nouveau s'établir en
afghanistan enfin beaucoup de questions
sur les profils justement des afghans
qui ont été évacués du pays ces
dernières semaines notamment ceux qui
sont déjà présents actuellement sur le
sol américain
on pourra noter pour finir que ces deux
auditions ont été le théâtre
d'affrontements idéologiques notamment
donc entre les républicains très
critiques contre les agissements de joe
biden et de son gouvernement
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et pour approfondir le sujet
nous sommes avec régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france bonsoir ses fils
merci d'être avec nous anthony blinken
inquiets beaucoup pointé du doigt
évidemment c'est le jeu la
responsabilité de l'administration trump
dans l'échec du départ américains hier
c'est donald trump acquis à rejeter la
responsabilité sur bayonne on semble
donc personne évidemment envie de porter
le chapeau mais finalement qui croire
dans cette histoire qui croire
évidemment il ya le jeu partisan donc on
s'attendait pas à ce que bill downe
disent oui c'est de ma faute excusez moi
devant le peuple américain au contraire
c'est vrai d'abord que c'est rome qui
est initié ce retrait mais ce retrait
les initiés dès l'époque obama est
d'abord retenu à l'époque obama ya eu un
seul jack c'est à dire plus de soldats
mais quand obama a vu que cette
stratégie ne marchait parle il a
commencé progressivement réduire le
nombre de soldats et a préféré préparer
un plan qui mettrait fin à cette guerre
donc ça date d'avant l'administration
trump trump lui aussi a pris les devants
en 2018 il retire 7000 soldats c'est
d'ailleurs à ce moment là que les
talibans constate que mathématiquement
sur le terrain ils peuvent reprendre
l'initiative et avoir le dessus donc les
talibans commence à grignoter le pays à
partir de 2018 à partir de place forte
dans les campagnes donc finalement ce
qu'on se rend compte c'est que voilà le
l'administration trône donne le feu vert
fait les accords avec les talibans
février 2020 donc accord de paix entre
l'armée américaine et le et le
les émissaires talibans de doha contre
l'avis du gouvernement afghan c'est une
bonne factuel mais et donc c'est joe
biden qui lui va décider du retrait en
fait qui va respecter ce calendrier mais
le problème principal qui incombe à
l'administration byden et sur lequel
anthony blinken a énormément de mal à
s'exprimer c'est le manque de
planification de ce retrait on sait que
par exemple les français dès le mois de
mai sur la paire ce avait avec pris
l'initiative de commencer à envisager le
rapatriement de leur traducteur d'un
certain nombre de gens ayant servi
l'armée française sachant qu'ils étaient
à risque tandis que la mère l armée
américaine et beaucoup d'autres nations
d'ailleurs les canadiens en particulier
n'avait toujours pas évolué sur ce sur
ce plan tout en sachant que de toute
façon à un moment ou à un autre l'armée
américaine allait se retirait donc que
le chaos qui a eu qui a eu lieu à la fin
ne peut en aucun cas être attribuée à
l'administration trump et est ce qui
s'est passé avant c'est uniquement la
responsabilité de deux de
l'administration byden et on se rend
bien compte 1 on a vu les l'airé des
sénateurs républicains dire vous nous
avez trahi à propos de 2,2 à anthony
blinken et et anthony blinken prend dans
certains cas être proprement incapable
de répondre certains sénateurs
d'ailleurs lui disant je ne veux même
pas entendre votre réponse je voulais
juste vous dire ça donc voilà donc le
chaos et le sentiment d'humiliation et
le sentiment que l'armée l'amérique et a
pris une gifle of finalement face à la
face au monde et bien ça c'est quelque
chose qui embarrasse l'administration
baden qui a fait baisser la cote de
popularité du président parce que les
américains évidemment n'aime pas se
sentir humilié quand même quelques axes
de défense en cas tenter anthony blinken
on a hérité d'une date limite mais pas
d'un plan de sortie anthony blinken qui
dit également que l'effondrement des
forces afghanes aussi peut-on était je
cite imprévisible même d'après des
spécialistes américains les plus
pessimistes c'est ce qu'il dit
non ça je vous dis ça c'est pas vrai du
tout
moi j'ai passé trois semaines en
afghanistan en juillet donc je suis
rendu dans le nez territoire taliban g
j'ai constaté d'ailleurs que les
talibans tout autour de kaboul mener des
attaques à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres du centre ville de kaboul
déjà en juillet je dirais que la plupart
des routes du pays était totalement
comment dangereuse et est très est
impraticable et les talibans il
procédait à des checkpoints et à dire
qu'ils avaient installé leur pouvoir il
avait commencé à gérer lors comment leur
a administré leur zone progressivement
grignotant le pays ne se ne s'attaquait
pas aux villes et quand ils ont commencé
à s'attaquer aux villes elles sont
tombées les unes après les autres
pourquoi parce que les talibans déjà
négocié avec les gouverneurs la ville de
djalal abad il ya deux mois de
négociations entre les administrateurs
censé être pro gouvernemental censé
dedans aux épaules et par les américains
et qui négocier avec les talibans ça
c'est d'aider des choses qu'on voit
assez couramment en afghanistan mais on
ne peut pas me faire croire que les
américains n'étaient pas au courant de
ces négociations étant donné que ça fait
20 ans qu'ils sont dans le pays qui a un
maillage des services de renseignement
et que je vous dis encore les français
semblait plus préparés à cette
éventualité d'un art et d'une arrivée
rapide des talibans
peut-être plus rapide que prévu que les
américains qui est finalement attendu au
dernier moment et on a vu la catastrophe
qui s'est produite effectivement vous
restez avec nous si vous le voulez bien
régis le sommier puisqu'on a évoqué avec
vous un autre sujet d'actualité
internationale la rencontre au sommet à
moscou entre le président russe vladimir
poutine et le président syrien bachar
el-assad les deux chefs d'état ont été
changées sur plusieurs sujets notamment
sur la présence jugée problématique des
forces étrangères en syrie ont fait le
point avant de s'en parler avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman
la situation politique la lutte contre
le terrorisme international et des
questions de coopération bilatérale
incluant l aide humanitaire et la lutte
contre la pandémie de coronavirus ont
été au menu des pourparlers des
présidents russe et c'est rien selon le
kremlin à la rencontre a eu lieu hier
matin au début de l'ère échanges
vladimir poutine a félicité son
homologue syrien pour le score de 95 % à
la présidentielle de et dernier selon
lui un tel soutien de la population
témoigne de la confiance envers les
autorités politiques malgré les
tragédies et les difficultés des années
précédentes le président russe s'est dit
également préoccupé par la présence des
forces étrangères sur le territoire
syrien écoutez je ne
l'imaginais c'est grâce à nos efforts
conjoints que la quasi totalité du
territoire de la république syrienne a
été libéré les terroristes ont subi des
pertes importantes
le gouvernement syrien avec vous à sa
tête contrôle 90% de son territoire le
problème le plus essentiel à mon avis
est que des forces armées étrangères
sont toujours présents dans certaines
parties du territoire du pays sans
l'autorisation des nations unies et de
votre gouvernement
de toute évidence cela va à l'encontre
du droit international et ne vous permet
pas de faire les plus grands efforts
visant à consolider et rétablir le pays
à un rythme qui serait possible si
l'ensemble du territoire étaient
contrôlés par le gouvernement légitime
c'est
bachar el-assad à son tour remercié la
russie pour son aide humanitaire y
compris le vaccin rue sainte ickowicz
foot nick v et a souligné que les armées
russe et sert y ont largement contribué
à la défense de l'humanité contre le
terrorisme international
écoutez non seulement nous forces armées
sont parvenus à des résultats
considérables dans la libération des
territoires occupés par les terroristes
et dans l'éradication du terrorisme mais
elles vont également faciliter le retour
des réfugiés qui avaient été contraints
de fuir leur foyer leur patrie
selon un communiqué de la présidence
syrienne la rencontre a porté sur la
coopération économique la lutte contre
le terrorisme et l'achèvement de la
libération des terres encore sous le
contrôle des rebelles pour rappel la
russie est intervenue militairement en
syrie en 2015 où ils disposent de bases
militaires permettant au gouvernement
syrien de regagner de la majeure partie
des territoires perdus face aux
jihadistes
régis se sont mis on vous retrouve donc
pour analyser et prendre un petit peu de
hauteur sur cette rencontre rare
rencontre d'ailleurs en tête à tête
entre n'est les deux hommes avec
évidemment on imagine aussi quelques
messages envoyés au reste du monde alors
oui évidemment rencontrera rhuys et
c'est le nom est le troisième je pense
déplaceront de bachar al assad a à
moscou donc faut l'organiser c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est pas simple
pour eux pour ce qu'on te lances qu'on
peut en dire effectivement dans l'idée
du message au reste du monde il vient de
se passer
le retrait dont on vient de parler des
américains en afghanistan et le
président russe et le président syrien
veulent apple d'affiché eux au contraire
l'idée qu' ils ont réussi à vaincre les
djihadistes en syrie qu'ils ont coopéré
que leur armée ont coopéré depuis
septembre 2015 et que aujourd'hui en
syrie en gros globalement le comment les
armées syrienne ont gagné la guerre et
et qu' il reste effectivement des poches
résiduelles de notamment dans la
province d'idlib qui a encore tenu par
des groupes djihadistes mais si vous
voulez par rapport à ce qu'a montré
l'amérique qui rend les clés aux taliban
dont carey groupe jihadiste sur tout un
territoire comme l'afghanistan c'est
évident que en comme en contrepoint
cette rencontre était là pour affirmer
affirmé que comment poutine et assad
avait réussi à détruire les terroristes
dans leur zone d'influencé activement
qui précise les terroristes ont subi des
dommages considérables en syrie où les
forces gouvernementales contrôlent selon
lui 90% du territoire
ça semble
réaliste effectivement ce chiffre c'est
le cas aujourd'hui alors c'est c'est le
cas oui on je sais pas si c'est 90% dans
l'os dans l'homme dans la mesure où il
ya aussi la zone contrôlée par les
kurdes qui est toujours appuyé par les
américains les américains contrôlent
toujours la zone des puits de pétrole
donc là il ya une vraie un vrai enjeu
diplomatique un vrai enjeu international
les comment les djihadistes contrôlent
toujours la zone d'idlib ils sont
appuyés de façon indirecte par la
turquie qui en a fait une sorte de
comment de protectorat l'on dira donc il
ya quand même encore beaucoup de monde
dans cette zone du nord les choses ne
sont pas absolument pas régler notamment
la question de dahiyat al et al cham
quand l'ancien front a nostra qui dirige
littéralement cette province d'idlib et
qui sont des djihadistes même si ces
djihadistes eux à la différence des
talibans peut-être nous avait on
recommande rompu leurs liens avec al
qaïda pour se faire bien voir on dira un
petit peu de la communauté
internationale mais non les choses ne
sont pas tout à fait réglé il ya eu une
insurrection qui est un peu passée à
comment sous que sous les feux de
l'actualité à cause de l'afghanistan
dans la ville de dera le problème
sécuritaire dans la ville de deraa a été
réglé une partie des combattants qui
s'étaient révoltés sont partis dans la
zone dite libre donc il ya eu à nouveau
une ville en insurrection en syrie donc
tout n'est pas réglé la question le
problème de la syrie ça a été évoqué
mais la syrie est sous sanctions
internationales donc c'est un pays qui a
qui manquent de tout dans lequel la
population et dont est tombé à un niveau
de misère considérable la livre syrienne
ne vaut plus rien donc il ya énormément
énormément de problèmes n'y a pas
d'investissement syrie en a trop peu et
on n'est pas à la phase de la
reconstruction il faudrait des milliards
de dollars est pour le moment le
séminaire l'art ne sont pas là donc on a
un bachar el-assad qui profitent
effectivement de cette tribune mais qui
aussi vient appuyer une sorte de
renaissance relative diplomatique dans
la région la crise au liban profite à la
syrie la crise grave le la spirale sans
fin dans laquelle et en étant fermés
liban profite à la série puisque les
américains ont accepté la semaine
dernière qu'il y ait des livraisons
d'hydrocarbures depuis l'egypte en
traversant le territoire syrien depuis
la jordanie d'électricité depuis la
jordanie en traversant également le
territoire syrien ça c'est à l'étude
pour la première fois une délégation
libanaise la semaine dernière s'est
rendu à damas donc il ya une sorte de
retour dans le jeu diplomatique de
bachar al assad on sait que en 2018
également les émirats arabes unis
avaient réouvert leurs ambassades à
damas depuis on s'était on avait dit oui
aura d'autres ambassades qui vont
réouvrir ça n'a pas été le cas mais un
certain nombre de pays comme l'irak
notamment poussent pour que la syrie
rejoindre à nouveau la ligue arabe ce
qui était une demande formulée donc si
vous voulez
bachar el-assad et dans toujours dans un
isolement diplomatique mais il est
relatif et il commence à se fissurer il
est évident que ce cet entretien à
moscou lui offre à nouveau une tribune
internationale
une manière de montrer qu'il est
toujours appuyé et c'est aussi une
manière pour vladimir poutine de montrer
que c'est toujours le maître du jeu en
syrie merci beaucoup aux régis le
sommier par ce décryptage merci à vous
on est toujours dans l'actualité
internationale quelques jours après à
les commémorations des attaques du 11
septembre 2001 khalid cheikh mohammed le
cerveau présumé de ces attaques est
entendue aujourd'hui par la justice
américaine détenue dans le camp
militaire de guantanamo et n'a toujours
pas été jugé comme lui 39 personnes sont
toujours détenus dans ce camp américain
à cuba les explications de guillaume un
rossi
c'est sans doute la photo la plus connue
du cerveau présumé des attentats du 11
septembre celle de l'arrestation de
khalid sheikh mohammed dans la nuit du
28 février au 1er mars 2003 suite à son
interpellation au pakistan il passe par
plusieurs prisons secrètes de la cia en
afghanistan ou encore en pologne où il
est torturé à de nombreuses reprises
avant d'être transféré ici à guantanamo
en septembre 2006 à guantanamo la prison
la plus célèbre au monde bâti au sud-est
de cuba là où le système carcéral
américain n'a pas cours washington y
envoie dès la fin de l'année 2001 des
prisonniers soupçonnés de terrorisme ou
en lien avec al qaïda les pires des
pires selon les mots de l'ex vice
président dick cheney dès les première
incarcération conditions de détention
traitements dégradants et diverses
tortures choc une partie de l'opinion
publique
très tôt il ya eu un sentiment
d'indignation mondiale à propos de ce
que les états unis faisaient
très tôt des rapports ont fait état des
détenus maltraités interrogé de manière
et l'idée même de détenir des personnes
indéfiniment sans inculpation a suscité
une grande indignation dans le monde
au plus fort de sa capacité guantanamo
accueille jusqu à 779 personnes de 48
nationalités différentes majoritairement
au début des années 2000 la population
du camp se réduit ensuite au fil des
années 532 prisonniers sont libérés
durant le mandat de george w bush près
de 200 autres pendant les années obama
le président démocrate qui avait fait de
la fermeture de la prison une promesse
de campagne non tenues dit obama
l'administration obama a fait un gros
effort pour l'affirmer mais n'a pas pu
le faire ils n'ont pas été en mesure d'y
parvenir ils ont fait beaucoup de
progrès ils s'en sont rapprochés ils ont
réduit la population carcérale mais
n'ont pas réussi à la ferme et la creuse
aujourd'hui 39 personnes sont encore
détenues à guantanamo la plupart n'est
toujours pas été jugés
et en israël des chiffres qui inquiète
depuis des années l'organisation des
nations unies a selon l'organisation
non-gouvernementale palestinienne
addameer israël détiendrait dans ses
prisons quelque 4600 50 palestiniens
dont 200 enfants 40 femmes et 520
détenus administratifs et situation des
enfants également évoqué avec
l'organisation save the children
dans leur rapport en 2020 plus de 80% et
aimé les avoir été battues physiquement
près de 90 % et les yeux bandés ou une
cagoule pendant leur détention et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
tel aviv avec paula slayer journalistes
rt internationale c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
mais bon soir pour la malheureusement un
problème technique nous empêche un
mauvaise liaison d'être en direct avec
vous on le fera donc par téléphone pour
commencer ces affirmations à ce qu'elles
sont fiables puisqu'elles sont quand
même d'une gravité assez importante
il lui faudra qu est mal et puis c'est
exact nous avons été nommés le dessus et
nous obtenons ces mêmes chiffres
admire qui est une organisation
pour les droits de l'homme et relâcher
les détenus
existe
y compris que cette organisation
surveille les trois humanitaires et les
procédures juridiques
et elle est soutenue par l'armée
israélienne entre autres alors je rappel
des chiffres qui sont assez édifiants
4650 pas les siens surtout 200 enfants
40 femmes ça paraît incroyable notamment
concernant les enfants que leur
reproche-t-on et quelles sont les
conditions de leur détention
il leur est reproché le jet de pierre et
la peine maximale c'est le vin en prison
d'après l'organisation save the children
serait la
donne pourrait légaliser l
être
légal juridiquement
possible d'arrêter et de détenir
mon père du
tribunal
et c'est pour cela qu'il ya ce qu'on
appelle beaucoup de détenus
administratifs
aujourd'hui quel est concrètement la
situation dans les prisons en israël
israélienne a été accusée
d'abus par des organisations
palestiniennes et disant que les
conditions sont indignes
2018 le ministre de la sécurité a formé
une commission spéciale pour étudier les
conditions de détention de ces détenus
sécuritaire j'en
sais il ya un contrôle
dans une certaine partie
du
droit de visite
la situation est-elle acceptable ou
mauvaises c'est difficile à dire
le mentaliste et prison a déclaré paul
hier
de trois évasions ont été empêchés
courte la nouvelle liste admirer go sony
et cette annonce faisait suite à
l'évasion des six prisonniers qu'ils ont
creusée
là sous leurs cellules pour quatre de
ses prisonniers une courte et rattraper
mais deux sont encore en liberté merci
beaucoup pour lier j'en ai certes et
internationales à d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir
en tunisie à présent le président essaye
toujours attendu sur sa feuille de route
et l'orientation qu'il souhaite donner
au pays et ce depuis le coup de force du
25 juillet dernier qui s'est soldé par
le gel du parlement et une série de
limogeages au sein du gouvernement selon
carthage il pourrait opérer un
changement du système politique
parlementaire les précisions à tunis de
notre correspondant cm chez be
c'est une déclaration qui n'a pas manqué
de susciter la colère d'une partie de la
classe politique tunisienne jeudi
dernier le conseiller diplomatique du
président sayed walid ajam avait déclaré
que le chef de l'état avait l'intention
de modifier le système politique dans le
sens d'un système présidentiel soumis à
un référendum populaire en d'autres
termes la suspension de l'actuelle
constitution et l'adoption de nouveaux
mécanismes politiques pour sortir de
cette crise une annonce qui est loin de
raisonner comme une surprise le
président ça aide ayant à plusieurs
reprises critiqué le régime
parlementaire tunisien et la loi
électorale invitant la classe dirigeante
à opérer des réformes en vue de la mise
en place d'un système présidentiel mais
ces réformes ne sont pas au goût de tous
deux partis politiques tunisiens la
volonté du peuple et le parti
républicain ont annoncé dimanche leur
rejet de toute tentative de suspension
de la constitution par le président de
la république je vous propose d'écouter
nous exprimons notre totale rejet de
toute tentative du président de la
république kaïs sayed de modifier la
constitution du pays sans respecter les
mécanismes définis par celle ci le parti
républicain exprime son rejet
catégorique des appels à suspendre la
constitution considérant qu'il s'agit
d'une mesure très dangereuse qui menace
de saper la légitimité sur laquelle
toutes les institutions de l'état sont
fondées des mesures dangereuses selon
ces députés à un risque pour les
institutions et les acquis démocratiques
de la révolution de 2011 samedi plus de
cent trois personnalités issues de la
classe politique tunisienne et de la
société civile ont signé une pétition
contre toute tentative de remise en
cause de la constitution face à ces
inquiétudes
le chef de l'état maintient son cap du
25 juillet faisant fi de toute critique
et poursuivant son opération main propre
hier dans un communiqué officiel la
présidence de la république a annoncé le
limogeage de la ministre de la jeunesse
et des sports par intérim si m haye a
dit rester
avec nous dans quelques instants c'est
demain que
négation vaccinale pour les personnels
des hôpitaux et maisons de retraite
plusieurs centaines de personnes des
milliers selon la cgt-santé ont
manifesté aujourd'hui contre cette
mesure alors est-il légitime d'opposer
libertés individuelles individuelle et
intérêt général ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
en suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier
elle permet à ses citoyens de se
prononcer sur les lois temps proposé et
même de les faire retirer éventuellement
en suisse il ya deux outils le premier
rideau mais d'attaquer les lois l'autre
instrument c'est l'initiative populaire
qui permet d'introduire un nouvel
article de la constitution fut tu mènes
que un sujet aride en votation signifie
qu' un problème ce qui oblige les les
partenaires politiques à se remettre
autour de la table parce qu'il pourrait
pas y avoir des dérives populistes vrai
que leurs proches ne risque de la voir
les votations sur des sujets dits
populiste
mais je pense malgré tout que le
meilleur moyen pour lutter contre le
populisme c'est précisément d'en
discuter et des tranchées
[Musique]
cette dernière année a été plutôt
heureuse pour les bouches les bourses
mondiales alors que la crise sanitaire
on n'est pas tout à fait terminée
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
cette hausse vous avez le les banques
centrales qui déversent des liquidités
massivement et les flèches vers la
bourse aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
aucune corrélation entre l'activité
réelle le pib et les marchés financiers
le jour où les banques centrales ont
décidé de tout arrêter tous les marchés
leur reviendront à la réalité on risque
d'avoir justement un éclatement de la
bulle est aujourd'hui l'action des
banques centrales est bien plus pervers
que ça parce qu'elle détruit l'économie
réelle de nos jours il n'ya aucun trader
qui n'ose aller contrer le marché parce
que la fille cette force en question
qu'est la force le des banques centrales
est trop forte
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser
l'extension du terrorisme ne faut pas
imaginer qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir
un pays pauvre pour que l'islam c'est un
bien acquis sont embrigadés ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide je
respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité les ide et courageuse
des mots qui comptent la haine françois
vient des murs passe aujourd'hui on ne
bouge pas extrêmement stylisées de mater
la société
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île interview
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
à
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission alors
que l'épidémie continue sa décrue en
france plusieurs centaines de personnes
des milliers même selon la cgt-santé ont
manifesté contre l'obligation vaccinale
qui s'appliquera appartient de demain au
personnel des hôpitaux et maisons de
retraite alors quelles sont leurs
arguments est il légitime d'opposer
libertés individuelles et intérêt
général comment les hôpitaux vont ils
s'adapter à cette nouvelle mesure du
gouvernement
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face
avec nos invités dans quelques instants
et on le disait donc l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants entre en
vigueur dès demain malgré de nombreuses
manifestations ces dernières semaines
une option prise par la france mais qui
n'est pas majoritaire avant les autres
pays d'europe on en parle tout de suite
avec alexis poulain dans son édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis donc entrer en vigueur un
demain de l'obligation vaccinale on l'a
dit une exception
quasi exception je dirais française en
europe quel est l'état des lieux
aujourd'hui alors il ya les états unis a
bien sûr qui eux veulent pour le
personnel fédéral
m la vaccination new york également et à
mesure en europe c'est différent la
france a choisi et ça c'était annoncé
dès cet été de vacciner les populations
au contact du public chez les soignants
pompiers mais pas les policiers ça
c'était l'exception que qui a qui a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre on a 2 7
millions de soigner en france on ne sait
pas demain combien ils seront à ne pas
être vaccinés certaines sources parlent
de 12 % en août soit 300 milles environ
soignants et personnels d pad qui serait
non vaccinés et donc il se vend se
retrouvait tout simplement suspendu qui
ne pourront pas travailler qui n'auront
pas de salaire il ça pose un problème
bien sûr puisque la question c'est
est-ce que l'hôpital peut continuer
comme ça est-ce qui aura pas une crise
de manque de bras alors que déjà on a vu
cet été les urgences étaient fermées par
manque de soignants donc c'est c'est
quelque chose qui va qui va poser
problème évidemment
le gouvernement lui se montre ferme
qu'il a dit de toute façon c'est la loi
et c'est demain loi d'exception puisque
là on est dans une loi qui est plutôt
contre le droit du travail plutôt qu'une
loi sanitaire et qu'est ce qui se passe
est bien là demain si jamais vous n'êtes
pas vacciné et bien vous serez suspendu
alors olivier ferrand a même demandé à
l'assurance maladie d'aller traquer ceux
qui seraient en arrêt maladie faculté
enfin il faut arrêt maladie pour pour
les sanctionner davantage donc on voit
bien que c'est un bras de fer que kate
engage le ministre avec les soignants
qui rappelons le lors des premières
vagues et bien été envoyé au front pour
soigner sans masquer les masques et est
moisi étaient détruits sans outil de
protection quasiment et sans vaccin
évidemment donc les choses ont beaucoup
changé alors c'est un combat où certains
médecins portent un du grain à moudre
l'infectiologue karine les cons qui
s'est fait remarquer aujourd'hui si vous
ne souhaitez pas vous faire vacciner
bien changer de métier le message est
clair et il est clair mais c'est plus
compliqué que ça chère madame lacombe
parce que des vaccins obligatoires y en
a déjà beaucoup et les soignants les
fonds sans rechigner là la question qui
se pose sur ce vaccin est pourquoi
certains le refuse c'est que ils ont
peut-être déjà eu la maladie maintenant
on voit des articles scientifiques qui
disent qu'une infection vaut quand même
une certaine protection et qu'une dose
suffirait la question aussi de
l'efficacité de la couverture vaccinale
sur le long terme combien de doses
va-t-il falloir quand on est soignants
en particulier donc on peut comprendre
que certains se posent des questions et
puis derrière ce problème finalement
deux cas c'est le droit du travail avec
ses lois d'exception permanence sous
prétexte sanitaires ça fait qu'on va se
retrouver avec un hôpital malade encore
plus malades qu'avant il ya un an de
savants locaux vides deux ans c'était
les urgences qui manifestaient dans les
urgences ça va pas mieux aujourd'hui on
a vu à l'appel de la cgt et d'autres
syndicats plusieurs milliers de
soignants qui étaient dans la rue pour
protester devant le ministère de la
santé demain il y aura des mobilisations
également de citoyens aides-soignants
devant les hôpitaux les ars l'idée c'est
de dire en fait qu'est ce que vous
voulez on a là certains leaders
syndicaux disait une loi de
discrimination qui n'a aucun sens d'un
point de vue sanitaire donc c'est la
vraie question d'autres disent que les
soignants qui font ça ne pense pas au
bien commun etc etc mais à partir du
moment où ce vaccin ne permet pas ou
alors limite certes la lal contagiosité
mais ça ne m'empêche pas néanmoins de
pouvoir redonner ce virus le transmettre
puis un autre problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus de 80 mille
postes sur pôle emploi dans le domaine
de la santé un qui sont les
aides-soignants les auxiliaires de santé
les professionnels de santé qui sont non
pourvus donc on est déjà avec un métier
qui n'attirent pas forcément les foules
qui ou la rue le recrutement est
difficile puisque le temps de la
formation et l'on est là que fait le
gouvernement une loi ubuesque de plus
pour dire aux gens eh bien vous ne
travaillerait pas alors qu'on a besoin
de vous c'est alors là on marche
vraiment sur la tête je sais plus
vraiment quoi dire mais il ya quand même
quelque chose dans ce jeu de poker
menteur parce que si jamais demain il y
avait beaucoup trop de problèmes dans
les services d'urgence ou dans les
services de soins des hôpitaux le
gouvernement a prévu une porte de sortie
qui est dans la loi une loi qui
permettrait finalement de suspendre
cette obligation vaccinale en fonction
de l'évolution de l'épidémie donc comme
on voit que la courbe est déjà quand
même descendante 1 et toutes les courbes
le monde depuis plusieurs semaines il se
pourrait que si jamais vraiment on va au
clash alors là le gouvernement lâche du
lest et c'est là que c'est un peu un
poker menteur c'est autre chose un des
centres de vaccination qui vont fermer
cet automne signe du succès de la
campagne oui alors c'était une annonce
aujourd'hui
effectivement les centres de vaccination
qui ferment alors soit c'est le succès
évidemment il ya eu beaucoup de gens qui
se sont fait vacciner soit c'est aussi
l'essoufflement de la campagne vaccinale
est toute la question maintenant c'est
est ce que les pharmaciens les médecins
vont pouvoir prendre le relais et à
quelle hauteur avec la troisième dose
les primo vaccinés qui veulent pas le
faire les autres et c'est donc les
affaire mais je crois que surtout
pourquoi on ferme c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement fermerait ses vaccinodromes
il ya une volonté politique aussi de
clore l'épisode du coc vide je crois que
ce qui va faire qu'on va s'en sortir
c'est d'abord la volonté politique de
dire j'ai géré la crise de la part d'
emmanuel macron et d'olivier verosvres
dans cocorico on a gagné on était les
meilleurs ce qu'ils disent depuis le
début alors que les chiffres montrent
quand même le contraire et donc on va
sans doute arriver à une fin politique
de cette épidémie parce que la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi
nous sommes encore dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire alors qu'on le voit
depuis enfin pas rester bon ben ça fait
plus de 18 mois donc on est on a mis la
démocratie entre parenthèses le
président gouverne avec des conseils de
défense sanitaire il ne rend de comptes
à personne alors ça arrive quand même la
cour de justice de la république demande
à agnès buzyn l'ancien ministre des
comptes ce sera peut-être le cas
d'edouard philippe dolivet véran on va
voir comment ça se passe ne revient que
politiquement à la fois il ya des voix
qui s'élèvent contre ce pass sanitaires
donc ça va pouvoir devenir un enjeu de
la campagne présidentielle d'une
certaine façon et que fait mme nelles
macron depuis quelques semaines
maintenant il est en campagne même s'il
ne le dit pas donc là clairement pour
couper l'herbe sous le pied de ceux qui
pourraient un gagné a à dire que le pass
à lithaire doit s'arrêter bien on va
peut-être dire que c'est fini et qu'on
va gérer cette épidémie comme une
politique de santé publique comme une
autre et donc pour ça il va falloir dès
novembre arrêté avec cet état d'urgence
permanent merci à l'ecti poulin et on en
parle et on l'a dit un mot lisa sion
donc partout en france à paris
mobilisation province à la veille de
l'entrée en vigueur de cette obligation
vaccinale pour les professionnels de
santé la cgt a donc appelé à manifester
partout mettant en garde contre une
catastrophe sanitaire car dès demain
infirmiers aides à domicile ambulanciers
ne pourront plus exercer s'ils n'ont pas
reçu au moins une dose de vaccin à paris
ceux qui dénoncent cette obligation
vaccinale se sont donné rendez vous
devant le ministère de la santé ont fait
le point avec notre reporter n'évite
khalifa
plusieurs centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant le ministère de la
santé afin de contester l'obligation
vaccinale à mais surtout les sanctions
prévues qui entreront en vigueur dès
demain si un soignant demain elle n'est
pas vaccinée elle son contrat peut être
suspendu et ça paye arrêter des
sanctions considéré comme anti
démocratique pour la plupart des
manifestants ici qui elle dénonce
également les conditions de travail un
des 16 hôpitaux la baisse des effectifs
mais aussi est la fermeture à delhi mais
aussi une certaine stigmatisation de ces
soignants non vaccinés considérés comme
des parias à cette heure ci alors que
l'année dernière il était applaudi lors
de la pandémie due coronavirus je vous
propose de l'écouter quelques-uns
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement a mis en
place
c'est une stratégie que je j'ai
interpellé très de populisme de
stigmatiser le personnel hospitalier en
rendant obligatoire la vaccination
qui en réalité
pratiquement plus de 90% du personnel
aujourd'hui sont vaccinés car c'est pas
le problème de la vaccination
aujourd'hui le problème c'est de vouloir
stigmatiser le personnel hospitalier de
l'hôpital public en leur disant c'est
vous les méchants et l'unsa on considère
qu'on croit en la science ont dit oui à
la vaccination comment peut-on imaginer
que des soignants soit contre la
vaccination par contre l'unsa dit non au
chantage par l'emploi l'unsa dit non à
ce qu'on transforme les héros d'hier en
[ __ ] d'aujourd'hui qui véhiculerait le
viser le virus l'unsa dit non à ce que
des collègues parce qu'ils ont peur
parce qu'ils hésitent demain se voient
privés d'emploi et donc privés de
rémunération
la majorité des collègues aujourd'hui
sont vaccinés mouvement de manière
contrainte par contre c'est de faire
entendre qu'à un moment donné les
soignants n'accepterons pas de nouveau
alors que depuis maintenant presque deux
ans ils sont dans le jus tous les jours
y'a pas de matériel ils ont manqué de
masse qu'ils ont manqué de tout et
aujourd'hui on les met au pilori en
disant c'est de votre faute si le virus
continue à se transmettre ça c'est pas
acceptable et il faut que le
gouvernement l'entende il faut que
monsieur véran l'entendre la dégradation
des soins pour les patients voilà la
conséquence directe de cette mesure qui
va engendrer forcément une baisse des
effectifs à travers les hôpitaux
français cela concerne environ à 10 %
des effectifs
les manifestants qui étaient présents
ici ont demandé à être reçus par le
ministre de la santé demande refusée par
olivier ferrand qui s'est d'ailleurs
montré intransigeant envers l'obligation
vaccinale concernant les soignants et
notamment les fraudes qu'il peut y avoir
pour les arrêts maladie notamment il a
annoncé que les contrôles allaient être
renforcées 1 durant ces prochains jours
en tout cas la mobilisation s'est
déroulée dans le calme entouré par un
important dispositif de sécurité aucun
débordement a signé
alors question philosophique l'intérêt
général doit-il primer sur l'intérêt et
la liberté individuelle est il légitime
d'opposer les deux de manière plus terre
à terre comment les hôpitaux dont ils
s'adapter à cette nouvelle mesure du
gouvernement c'est l'objet de notre face
à face avec nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir ou
une ome garbade chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bonsoir ou renommer garden merci
d'être avec nous tous à vos côtés
ghislain cabantous vice-président de la
ceppm de l'hérault vous est également
membre de la commission exécutive de la
fédération cgt à un santé et action
sociale la cgt qui appelait à manifester
aujourd'hui bienvenue à tous les deux
alors il faut convaincre plutôt que de
contraindre avait dit le leader en
justement de la cgt philippe martinez
avant vous faire réagir mais sur
regarder ces chiffres au 7 septembre
selon santé publique france qu'elle est
donc l'état des lieux 88,1 % des
médecins dans les hôpitaux ou ehpad ont
reçu au moins une dose ça veut dire si
les calculs sont donc il est un peu plus
de 10% ces professionnels de santé qui
ne sont pas vaccinés ce sont clairement
les derniers irréductibles ghislain
cabantous
je ne parlerai pas de directives ni des
derniers ce sont des professionnels de
santé qui ne souhaitent pas se faire
vacciner parce que la vaccination va
contre leur conscience c'est parce
qu'ils estiment que un danger potentiel
qui n'est pas géré donc je ne parle pas
des réducs tible je parlerai de gens qui
ont un avis scientifique un avis de
professionnel qui est différent de celui
qui est porté par le gouvernement
notamment et qu'il ne faudrait pas
amalgamer non plus l'ensemble des gens
vaccinés à une position qui serait
extrêmement favorable au vaccin puisque
beaucoup ont été forcés de le faire
renault megane quand vous entendez donc
c'est ses arguments et les arguments
qu'on a entendues dans les cortèges est
ce qu'il y a quand même un peu de bon
sens et des arguments qui font écho chez
vous
écoutez je comprend effectivement que
l'on puisse avoir une certaine opinion
un peu différente de celle de la
communauté scientifique des autorités
sanitaires du pays qui recommande
fortement ce vaccin dont nous savons
aujourd'hui de façon définitive
qui non seulement protège contre les
formes graves de la maladie mais aussi
réduit de façon de reste que la
contamination
donc effectivement on peut tout à fait
avoir des idées opposées que je respecte
néanmoins une loi était votée dans le
pays je pense elle s'impose à tous et
donc de fait effectivement demain tous
les soignants devraient être vaccinées
ne serait ce que pour être
dans le respect de la loi en tout cas on
l'a constaté guy les uns cabantous le
ton monte depuis la rentrée il ya des
conversations parfois tendues y compris
dans des dîners de famille je vous
propose d'écouter l'infectiologue
aujourd'hui karine lacombe
on ne veut pas se faire vacciner on
change de métier quand on s'engage dans
le soin on pense aux autres et penser
aux autres c'est faire en sorte d'être
vacciné et protéger pour ne pas se
contaminer et pour ne pas contaminer les
autres ghislain cabantous qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez à karine je voudrais
déjà répondre au docteur qui est mon
contradicteur en quelque sorte pour dire
que les personnes qui refusent de se
faire vacciner ne contreviennent pas la
loi la loi elle dit que ce n'est pas
vacciné au 15 on va être suspendu et
donc les personnes ne vont pas
contrevenir à la loi doit être suspendue
en revanche ces personnes sont
indispensables au système de santé et
donc nous avons des informations comme
quoi de nombreux hôpitaux de nombreux
établissements de santé pourrait les
faire travailler malgré tout et dans ce
cas là ce sont ces institutions qui
contreviendrait à la loi effectivement
c'est une loi qui n'est pas applicable
c'est une loi qui est liberticide qui va
à l'encontre de nombreux textes
internationaux parce qu'elle aime pose
des choses aux soignants elle réduit
leur liberté individuelle or cette
réduction ne peut intervenir qu'en
dernier recours c'est à dire s'il n'y a
pas de médicaments s'il n'y a pas de
solution or il ya des solutions à ces
solutions sont interdites et c'est ça le
problème de cette loi qui est une
mauvaise loi et qui doit être combattue
par tous les moyens
renault megane liberticide qui doit être
combattue par par tous les moyens
non évidemment je ne suis pas d'accord
donc monsieur évoque les solutions et
bien la solution principale c'est la
vaccination
s'il revenait quelques mois en arrière
il se souviendrait que lors de la
troisième vague est bien là qu vide et
est devenue la principale cause
d'infection nosocomiale et bien ne
serait ce que dans mon service à peu
près 20% des personnes qui ont été
hospitalisées pour fois me grave de la
maladie dont certains sont décédés et
bien ont été contaminés à l'hôpital
probablement pour la majorité d'entre
eux par des soignants pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement et c'est ça le danger
de cette maladie je n'incrimine pas les
soignants
c'est malheureux c'est que ce virus
peut-être responsables notamment chez
les plus jeunes ceux qui sont en bonne
santé de forme strictement
asymptomatiques donc la personne ne se
sait pas contaminés et bien rentrer à
l'hôpital peut contaminer les patients
mais aussi ses collègues etc c'est de là
que vient le danger car nous avons
observé évidemment des clusters au sein
des services notamment par contamination
entre les soignants eux mêmes et qui par
la suite ne sachant pas porteurs du
virus et bien pourrait le porter aux
patients et c'est ce qui a été observé
l'esprit est bien de cette loi
évidemment c'est premièrement de
protéger les soignants eux mêmes contre
le risque de tomber malade et donc de
devoir être absent à leur poste et donc
de mettre en difficulté le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital et surtout
évidemment d'éviter de contaminer
directement les patients parce qu'ils
seraient porteurs du virus sans le
savoir donc je crois que cette loi a
bien sûr beaucoup davantage c'est le
moyen principal malheureusement pour
nous aujourd'hui il n'existe pas de
thérapeutiques médicamenteuses
permettant d'éviter la contamination et
permettant de réduire de façon drastique
le risque de faire une forme grave de la
maladie en dehors du vaccin bilan qu
qu'avant tout quand vous entendez ces
arguments effectivement qui ressorte qui
sont ceux qui ressortent tout le temps
d'intérêt général les arguments que
viennent de nous décrire le docteur
megan qu'est ce que concrètement vous
répondez
concrètement je réponds qu'il ya
beaucoup de conditionnel dans les propos
du docteur est aussi qu' il faut tenir
compte du bénéfice risque alors d'une
part lorsque vous vacciner quelqu'un
vous ne pouvez pas à lui affirmé qu' un
il ne développera pas la maladie 2 il ne
va pas la transmettre et 3 il n'aura pas
d'effets indésirables graves autrement
dit quelqu'un de vacciner va se
retrouver dans le statut de
contamination dans même titre que
quelqu'un qui n'est pas vacciné il
existe des solutions il existe les tests
il existe des médicaments alors certes
ces médicaments qui sont l'ivermectine
par exemple midane existe beaucoup le
lac l'euro/livre odile roxy chloroquine
par exemple et c'est le protocole qu'à
appliquer professeur out certes ces
médicaments sont eux ne sont pas
considérés comme une thérapie en france
en revanche ils le sont à d'autres pays
et cela fonctionne donc on est sur une
espèce d'emprise où il avait le
juridique le politique et le médical qui
sont liés dans une espèce de
raisonnement astucieux pour obliger les
gens consentir à une thérapie qui n'a
pas fait ses preuves notamment dans le
temps on ne sait pas ce que cette
thérapie peut donner dans le temps et
donc on fait donc un pari et quand on
regarde ailleurs ce qui se passe en
israël j'étais très surpris de voir le
gouvernement israélien qui disait mais
attention les personnes vaccinées deux
fois on doit être vacciné notre
troisième fois d'urgence et en priorité
parce que c'est paradoxal elles sont
plus fragiles au coït 19 dont vous voyez
qu'on fait des raccourcis et on va très
très vite au lieu de choisir des
solutions simples qui sont de soigner à
aucun moment on ne pourra remplacer un
système de soins par un vaccin et moi je
pose la question pourquoi on continue de
fermer des lits pourquoi mille huit
cents lits ont été fermés depuis le 1er
janvier 2020 alors qu'on pouvait savoir
qu'ils allaient être nécessaire c'est
une volonté de remplacer un système de
soins par un vaccin parce que c'est
moins cher en revanche on fait fi de la
sécurité renault mégane la réponse est
vrai que cet exemple il serait un lien
revient souvent
lorsqu'on évoque effectivement
l'obligation vaccinale qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez vous répondre en tant qu' en
tant que justement médecin
alors je suis désolé de ce que je viens
d'écouter comporte un certain nombre d'
amalgame malheureusement faut alors tout
d'abord un vaccin n'a jamais empêché une
contamination tous les vaccins
classiques que nous connaissons
n'empêche pas la personne d'être
contaminée par l'agent infectieux par
contre elle le protège contre la forme
grave de la maladie et le protège contre
le risque de mourir et c'est l'objectif
du vaccin ici avec le vaccin témoin à
combien % pardonnez-moi la laine le côté
concret de la question
on sait que le vaccin contre la coved
réduit par un facteur de 8 à 10 le
risque de développer une forme grave de
la maladie et c'est extrêmement
important notamment pour les personnes
pour doctorants jeune et courageuse et
l'utilité de la maladie le risque pour
un jeune de 18 ans de développer la
maladie ou de moins de 30 ans
bien sûr sans risque est beaucoup plus
faible malgré tout le vaccin le protège
contre le risque éventuel non seulement
de formes graves mais aussi de kovy de
long alors le deuxième point important
effectivement c'est que les traitements
dont vous avez parlé c'est à dire
hydroxy chloroquine
l'ivermectine est bien ne faut pas mieux
que le placebo c'est à dire ne font pas
mieux que l'eau salée pour réduire le
risque de faire évoluer la maladie vers
une forme malheureusement plus graves
donc attention aux illusions
malheureusement ces médicaments ont été
démontrés par des essais thérapeutiques
de très haut niveau de preuve comme
insuffisant pour modifier le cours de la
maladie
vingt derniers cités mais s'il vous
plaît parce que je suis très étonné
parce que moi j'ai entendu qu'on est ici
avait été interrompue en france je n'ai
pas entendu connaissez avec démon et que
ces médicaments n'était pas efficace
alors ce ne sont malheureusement pas
appuyer pour la recherche française les
essais français qui ont pu le démontrer
ce sont des essais internationaux
notamment anglais mais aussi
nouveau et landais et australiens qui
ont permis de démontrer
l'absence malheureusement d'intérêt de
tous ces médicaments et elle fait les
positions de leurs abonnés des sources
pour le ciridd un dernier point dernier
point important attention la troisième
dose est un rappel donc effectivement
des rappels il en existe pour tous les
vaccins c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait normal donc il faut pas prendre ça
pour un signe d'inefficacité du vaccin
mais simplement une marque de
renforcement de l'immunité en réponse à
la vaccination pour permettre
effectivement de préserver cette réponse
dans le temps notamment chez les
personnes les plus âgées dont le système
immunitaire plus vieillissant répondent
de façon moins optimale à la vaccination
donc rappel ne veut pas dire vaccin
inefficace au contraire guina cabantous
demain quelle va être l'attitude de vos
collègues qui ne souhaitent pas se faire
vacciner ils vont réagir comment ils
vont être suspendus ils vont venir au
travail certains vont se mettre en arrêt
maladie vous avez pu discuter autour de
vous ils vont venir au travail ils vont
attendre de voir ce que l'administration
fait deux je suppose qu'on va leur
donner un courrier pour leur annoncer
qu'ils sont suspendus et à partir de là
ils déposeront des plaintes puisque
cette suspension contrevient c'est une
attaque contre un grand nombre de textes
du travail c'est une attaque contre le
statut des fonctionnaires c'est une
attaque contre le code du travail eh
bien ils vont déposer des plaintes
probablement en référé et du coup bien
sur le long terme pour résister à cette
à ces attaques
bruno mary harron de votre côté vous
êtes chef de réanimation dans un grand
hôpital vous craignez un
dysfonctionnement une pénurie on sait
que il ya déjà des problèmes de
personnel dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux
est-ce qu'il ya il ya sept
ce paramètre qu'il faut prendre en
compte
alors donc heureusement pour le service
de réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière
l'ensemble du personnel médical et
paramédical a été vaccinée sera donc
parfaitement en règle dès demain par
contre dans l'hôpital lariboisière
effectivement il est probable qu'une
trentaine de personnels soignants ne
souhaitait ne souhaitant pas se faire
vacciner ne le seront pas demain alors
il faut savoir qu'on ne saura exactement
le nombre de personnes qui n'a pas reçu
sa première dose donc il n'a pas
commencé son cycle de vaccination demain
uniquement demain car jusque là
évidemment couverts par le secret
médical n'était pas possible de deux on
va dire d'examiner la totalité des
certificats de vaccination du personnel
alors évidemment ceci va constituer une
difficulté importante pour certains
services
j'espère évidemment que en connaissant
les personnes encore non vaccinés
lorsqu'ils seront convoqués
à la direction des ressources humaines
il sera encore possible de faire de la
pédagogie de discuter avec eux d'essayer
de les aider au cas par cas bien sûr je
suis tout à fait favorable à ce que le
principe de réalisme prime et
qu'évidemment les activités
de soins ne soit pas perturbée par ces
quelques personnes qu'il faudrait
retirer du soin on verra évidemment dans
quelle situation on saura on ne sait pas
mais je trouve dommage évidemment qu'on
puisse arriver une telle situation et
que certaines malheureusement convaincu
par des fakes news persiste à croire que
le vaccin n'est non seulement pas
efficace mais aussi dangereux c'est
totalement fou merci en tout cas tous
les deux bruno mes gars ben aguida
cabantous d'avoir accepté ce face à face
et d'avoir plus entendre en tous les cas
vous arguments tous les deux merci et
c'est la fin de cette émission rendez
vous demandez 20h prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]